now is the winter of our discontent made
glorious summer by the sun of york
and all the clowns delight upon our
house in the deep bosom of the ocean
laid
buried now
our eyebrows bound with victoria's
wreaths
our stunner adams changed to merry
meetings
i'll our bruised arms hung up for
monuments grim visage dwarf has smoothed
its wrinkled front
and now instead of
mounting bobbitt's teeth
to fright the souls of fearful
adversaries
he capers dimly in the ladies chamber
to the lascivious pleasings of elite
but i that i'm not
shaped for sportive tricks
not made to caught an amorous looking
glass i
that i'm so rudely stamped and want
love's majesty just struck before i'm
unsung wombling nymph
i let him curtailed of this fair
proportion
cheated a feature by descending nature
deformed
unfinished sent before my time into this
breathing world scarce half made up and
that's so labeling
and unfashionable that even the dogs
bark at me
as i hope by them
why i in this week
piping time of peace have no delight and
pass away the time
so western spy
my own shadow in the sun
and then scunt on my own deformity
therefore since i cannot prove a lover
to
entertain these farewell spoken days i
am determined to prove
a villain and hate
the idol pleasures of these days
you